why don't we just play 1979 did you and  an acoustic guitar  [Music]  shakedown  [Music]  livewire  about the stream you and I  me  [Music]  Jill bug skipping like a stone  with the headline  wanted and  [Music]  we were sure we'd never seen  [Music]  [Applause]  here  to shake these  [Music]  we down  it's where our puzzle  I  Oh God in  [Music]  to the  love  [Music]  double-crossed eBay  [Music]  Lenna charge is why we  in stone  mommy  and  [Music]  as restless as we  we feel  [Music]  to the line  it's now  [Music]  to speed  [Music]  we saw  we go  [Music]  the sound  how  [Music]  just stain  calm down with those freaks and  apologies and  [Music]  XANA you  [Music]  you can fake it  [Music]  run care  the shake things  [Music]  love  straight it's the  [Music]